thrilled to have on the show i saw what
he had to say on pardon the interruption
yesterday and on espn about his beloved
chicago bears and i said basically a
text please bestow us the honor of uh
phone uh phoning into our program
tomorrow he said yes
and he is here he is michael wilbon uh
from pardon the interruption how are you
sir
i'm good especially uh with that uh
lead-in of
all brotherhood i mean you know
i took i took it off in 1994
so it's i'm coming up on 30 years so
that's when you tap down no hair you're
tapping
the notion the notion that you know of
toupees and
right you know sowing you know seeds in
your head
what are people talking about man i tell
people if i had known
the reaction that i was going to get
particularly i
particularly from women at the time i
would have shaved it all off when i was
11.
this is not this is not you know i mean
you know
guys who shave not guys who look like
tony and go
have to keep the the the side panels if
you shave it off you're not
people aren't looking back you don't see
people who shave their heads
matu grown men i'm not talking about 20
something's playing basketball
you don't see mature mango oh i lament
the loss of my hair take it off dude
get rid of it well i think i saw the
other day that shaq because he lost a
bet had to grow his hair in to see what
it looked like so
wha what would you have that tells you
you lose a bet now that's the only way
you grow it back if you're ashamed so
what would yours look like now would you
have the horseshoe is that what it would
look like
oh i'm sure i guess i've never even
tried it i've haven't i've been tried
one i shaved pretty much every other day
a radical departure is a fourth day
having three days of hair i don't ever
have it so i don't know well you know
the person doesn't have to worry about
the person who's constantly after me to
to to you know uh put hair on my head
is the current jackson state head coach
dominating
in the hbcu uh football world dion dion
says that he was the company there you
go
dion said he was the comeback player of
the year as soon as he put his hair back
on he says it's by just what he called
himself the comeback player of the year
all right michael let's get to the
matter at hand um
your your two cents for this audience uh
on the andy dalton signing uh uh by the
chicago bears
have the floor it has nothing to do with
andy dalton the story of the bears and
and and signing of andy dalton doesn't
do any adult
it has to do with uh once again the
bears are inadequate at the position of
quarterbacks
which they've been um i mean they've
really been that
since jim mcmahon
that that's what they've been i mean
don't don't don't anybody ever try to
tell me that jay cutler
mattered i don't care if he made a pro
bowl or not he didn't because he was so
much less
than even what he promised if you
remember jay cutler used to say my arm
is stronger than john ellis
so what dude so what
this is it's amazing that
um the the signature one of the
signature franchises the founding
franchise of the nfl
just doesn't understand how to acquire
the most important position in north
american sports
don't know how to do it they know how to
draft one
build one trade for one sign
one nothing and so
this general manager how this guy ryan
pace is allowed to even
try to acquire one when he's the guy you
know what
chicago the most famous athlete in
chicago history rich
was passed over by another team the
portland trailblazers
even though they had clydra and they had
a reason you could say wait a minute we
sort of have
come out of college we think that clyde
drexler a guy who's a member of the
dream team
a hall of famer a final four
member in college and uh a nba champion
we've got
him so we're we're we're not gonna
sort of duplicate that that's the logic
there that's not illogical
it didn't work not to the tune of jordan
but it didn't work
ryan pace not only passed over
patrick mahomes who was seen as the best
player in the league today
he passed over to sean watson in the
same draft
picking higher you don't have to move up
you just gotta take one of them
that guy is entrusted to then continue
on
to fix the quarterback problem and this
is what he comes up with
i mean i you know the notion that they
were gonna get russell wilson was to me
insane
i got a crying 13 year old in my house
gurus for the same team as his father
and every day he would come to me
dad we resigned you know robinson
and wide receiver doesn't that mean
we're going to get rust no
it doesn't it doesn't mean that it means
we're going to do the same
it means we're going to get mike phipps
30 years later
40 years 40 years probably mike phipps
that's what we do
that's our move and by the way i'm not
even saying that he could have gotten
them i'm just saying the notion
he's gonna go aggressively and take a
big swing and offer the whole team
you know what you could have said five
years ago it was the 2017 draft right
you could have just said it with the
so-and-so pick in the draft i think it
was third
the chicago bears take fill in the blank
desean watson
deshaun watson fill in the blank
bachelor mahomes patrick mahomes
he didn't do either he wouldn't got a
guy who had started 11 times in college
and by the way i don't think miss
trubisky is a bad quarterback
especially if he had a coach who wanted
to coach him
instead of wanting to make somebody fit
the system or go out and get a
a a statue you know um who won a super
bowl for philadelphia
they the two of them the combination of
them rich
it's it's infuriating yeah i mean you've
said that before michael and i i want to
pull on that string a little bit right
here michael wilbon from pardon the
interruption our friend from
the worldwide leader in sports you've
said that before on on your last
appearance that
that maggie doesn't want to didn't want
to coach trubisky doesn't want to coach
him didn't want to coach him and yet
he took the job knowing it was his job
to fix him and one coach of the year by
in by in so doing so what do you mean by
that
i mean i've had kansas city chiefs
players tell me to my face and i'm not
going to name them
these were off the record conversations
i probably shouldn't be mentioning
a couple of two years ago when they the
super bowl that
they knew that he didn't want to call he
didn't want to coach him it was
it's not a secret when i say didn't want
to coach him he preferred
he had patrick mahomes as a red shirt
that's not the same skill set is coming
to coach trubisky
and everybody knows it it's when i say
it's an open secret they're
they're former bears and i don't mean
just guys from 85
i mean therefore they're they're recent
former bears who i run into and they go
gee no he doesn't want to coach this guy
he wants somebody with a different skill
set
but this is not something that we do in
mass media rich we don't criticize the
coaches too often
we and and on sundays the guys in the
booth or even
either ex-coaches or quarterbacks who've
had great relationships with their
coaches the coaches don't really get
criticized in the nfl they really don't
and this is this is this is not my own
observation
this is me putting the reporter back
back on just listening
and maybe a 10 percent observation but
90 listening
to people who are in the industry of
football
i mean just look at look at look at the
plays that were called look at how the
offense ran
earl in trubisky's best games in his
best time
look at how disgusted he gets with what
the planes calls for him
look at look at i mean his own
development look at what he was when he
came into the league in the second year
the bears go
12-4 and i think he was ten and three in
that time he missed a couple of years
so what and i i i this
is not this should not be treated like
rocket science it isn't rocket science
and there's too many people who know and
too many people who believe in it too
many people who know
and have spent years and years and years
and years in the nfl for whatever it is
they do
and they know so this is this is you
know this may be
too much inside baseball around the rest
of the country in chicago it is not
and so now they've gone
and they've replaced trubisky
essentially they're gonna bring him back
too i don't i mean they don't need to be
inside of that
oh so what are they doing that would be
something else if they brought him back
michael wilbon here uh on the rich eisen
show and
just a push back a little bit here uh as
you know the bears
um uh uh tried for russell
they took their swing we hear from our
colleague dan patrick
about you know three first-rounders two
starters some other
choices by the way well but but even
even that though
you know i would if i'm seattle i would
have told him to forget it too with a
coach who's pushing 70
and and and geno smith as the
alternative
that's currently sitting right there for
the moment and you know
um other alternatives that are around
out there are not even close to russell
wilson and you can't even get up to
close to the top
uh five from their position because they
they've already coughed up their first
round draft choices this year next you
can't even package what the bears give
them with what
they already have so they don't have so
it was it's just not a match certainly
in a way that say
the jets or miami or uh you know
that it's not imagine the same way that
the other team it's not a match to
acquire him
now no i'm not angry about now i'm
this is retroactive anger they had a pic
rich
they could have just walked to the mic
and said the chicago bears with the
third pick of the draft
select desean watson
there's no push back on that this is the
same guy
this is the same gm they could have
walked to the mic and said the chicago
bears the third period select patrick
mahomes
no they weren't going to get russell
wilson this time
that was a fraud that was just
garbage they weren't going to come close
they don't have the assets
and to tear up the whole team what kind
of team would russell wilson
be quarterbacking if they had given all
that away to get him
i agree with you i never thought it was
a fit from the beginning
but uh that said though you know that's
you're already hearing from the bears in
many other places that they're they're
definitely talking to members of our
of our profession to say we tried and
and we didn't even ask for it that's
what peter schrager said in our number
one
someone from the bears told him we
didn't even ask that that it was his
agent who put it out there
uh to adam schefter that uh he'd like to
go to chicago and as soon as that
happened we pounced we
we try to make it happen they even had
some meeting in north dakota apparently
yeah trey lance's pro day and they try
to make it happen so
the guy who he tried to rectify the
mistake that you said the original sin
i guess to use your uh analogy here
there's no rectifying that
it set the franchise back at least 10
years it's going to be 10 years
unless they come up with something or
andy dalton you know
has a um i don't know a trend guilford
season it's possible he's a veteran guy
who's got a better than 500 records brad
johnson's not about dalton like brad
johnson
he could do the bread there's another
one that's right that's a good that's
another good
um uh point rich but the point is not
that they
fail to get him now they were never
getting him now
they don't have the assets to get him
now this points out
that no matter what they do the
franchise cannot
get a quarterback rich how many how many
pro bowl and i haven't looked this up
i guess cutler had one pro bowl
appearance didn't he
i think he did and jim mcmahon must have
had at least one
i i mean what are we talking about jim
mcmahon's best season
was 35 years ago
and we're still dining off that i saw
jim in uh in arizona not too long ago
and i just said he got eligibility left
and he just started laughing i mean this
is this is a hundred years and you got
like
four quarterbacks that you want to pick
on your roster
so what do you what what would be the
fix for
for you michael because you're clearly
giving a bunch a voice to a ton of
bears fans that still can't get over
what ryan pace did
atop the draft in philadelphia those
years ago so
what what what would be the the solve
blow everybody out start from scratch
yeah i think so i think so i think you
have to have people who
and by the way like i i you know there's
some venom being directed at the
mccaskeys i don't have any of that
i mean they basically say this is not
you know we try to hire football people
to do this we're not he's not meddlesome
he's not meddlesome george not
meddlesome at all but
it may have to be okay let let me hire
someone who can
tell me who to hire because this this is
not
working um this isn't this isn't working
and it doesn't
look you know i thought okay um when you
go 12 and four
and even after you you you lose a game
that
you know how can the coach and gm help
that i don't know maybe have a better
kicker but i'm not gonna blame them for
that
the double joint game i thought okay
this is this
seems to be really headed in the right
direction
well it's not in the right direction
rich
and it hasn't been headed in the right
direction since they fired lovey smith
they fired lovey smith coming off a 10-6
season
in which to me the solution then was to
call norb turner
and say to lovey lovey we are gonna fire
you here's your offensive coordinator
we're gonna give you the best guy in the
game today or one of the three best
to finish this thing that you can't
quite finish super bowl appearance
nfc title game appearance fire them off
ten and six
how's that gone since so you you you
have to have people at the top
of this football operations people i'm
not talking about the owner
there's no toxic owners not that he
wants to win
but no wanting to win and knowing how to
win at two different things but
i think you know i've gotten god the
number of texts generated yesterday
you know um we tell you inside baseball
we
rich we tony and i had pretty much
decided on what was going on to pti and
taped it
when the when the andy dalton news came
in
and i did not want to go back into the
show and i said all you guys are going
to do
my producers is make me angry and make
me
nuts yeah there but that's five good
minutes michael yeah at least yeah
it is rich and they knew what they were
doing right
you know and they just turned and walked
away from the fire uh from the brush
fire that i of course you know
was happy to throw gasoline on so but i
got but let me just tell you this
yes so of all the people rich i buy
tickets to go back to bear's game
i don't go as a credential i'm not i'm
not a credentialed reporter covering the
bills i don't do that anymore
i buy tickets because my son says oh
damn we got to go
i've never seen tom brady in my whole
life in person your whole life you're
11. what are you doing
we'll go we fly back i buy tickets to
see brady
two years ago last time we could go dad
can we go see patrick mahomes
yeah this is going to make me angry
fly out and see patrick mahomes play
against the bears
so we do i do this every year i love
doing it
but you know what before i die
i would like to see a competent
quarterback
that's all and i don't think the guys
there
can create that at the top of the
football operation
not the owner i'm talking about ryan
pace
and i'm talking about matt maggie and
these guys are not dumb they are not
stupid
they are not they are professional
football people
but they don't seem to be able to get
this right
and and and i'm talking about whoever
they could have taken
whoever they did take how's it working
bottom line
sports is the greatest bottom line thing
how is it working i don't want to hear
the excuses
i don't want to hear from pr i don't
want to hear spin
i don't want to hear what they tried how
many teams have signed quarterbacks in
the last
30 years rich
almost all of them almost all of them
i mean i live in a city where joe gibbs
won three super bowls with three
different quarterbacks yep he wouldn't
got
doug williams from another league
this is this is not this is you know i
mean but again we don't really
you know players get criticized the
coaches get criticized for game day
decisions
if things don't work out but but the
overall overarching kind of criticism
that says what what are you
doing that you know
that goes insulated for the most part
michael thank you for responding to my
text amongst the
no doubt avalanche of texts have you
come on this show
i always forward you a few last night
and i decided for
many from people that you know yes i'm
sure you have covered but i decided to
spare you are angst out in the great
midwest
and so i'm happy to come on and spend
some more with you my dear old always
appreciate that
best to mr tony please and everybody
else on the set down all right be good
now we'll chat again soon there you go
they broke the mold one of my favorites
michael wilbon dude the best
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here